I wanted to give a little live Congrats
little drop drop the knowledge that I
had I heard two really cool Japanese
concepts at my friend Hunter mots
explained on mixed mental arts my other
podcast what well do you know for ten
points do you know the two Japanese
concepts of iki guy and kutsuki Katsuji
yeah kutsuki is you know what I like to
do to make a sound and see if it's an
Asian circuit do it in China tell you
alright you know I ain't going down
you still got country what about this
one dude do you I'm not a kid that
sounds Vietnamese boom Rock one and this
is why when you are a guy who you know
is you and you're what five 170 right
how you characterize doesn't matter
because boxing and [ __ ] and the reason
it made me laugh from the bottom of my
gut is that if you ever step to me give
a [ __ ] if we're in the theater class
yeah don't give a [ __ ] if we're on a
cruise to me or where we are especially
respectful I'll fold you a full jet no
yes and I'll toss you on top of the
tallest building I see no have a look
around I love that if there's a
two-story building the seams here what
are we on the third floor here yeah so
this has got three floors this place
yeah all the all the places in this
whole complex three pretty cool stuff
yeah there's lots of great [ __ ] outside
there's as I was walking in I saw a food
truck yeah everyone was ordering stuff
yeah careful now looks like it's a good
thing yeah if we were out there and I
was in line and I was like yeah hi
chicken Caesar no croutons and then you
walked up and you shoved me out of the
way and you would three food store cool
and I would just fold you and turn you
around
I would start spear and I go there it it
and it's like oh there's one and three
stories up [ __ ] you you'd wake up the
gravel rash on the roof just crumpled up
against an air-conditioning unit what
the [ __ ] happens it grabbed you
you'll get gravel rash they'll be up
there tar in the gravel with their hot
mops and you'll go watch you got a
little you're hot it's hot up there you
got some tar on guitar you got gravel
rash in public yes little bony in my
pants yeah a little [ __ ] a little [ __ ]
in your pants listen I appreciate what
you're saying and I get it I'm not a
regular guy I got a lot of tricks here
that's the same thing as Chad I'll get
will in the wind again I've been sitting
down the punches lately doing a lot of
sparring a measuring time's up on hunch
stop calling women huh delivery are you
ordering some mr. good bars was that to
get your oh Henry [ __ ] man sweetie okay
sweetie by doing no hon I'm recording a
show I don't know what's happening right
now B what's happening I've been here
since 12:15 you won't know these names
but would you rather be Tom Brady and
Derek Jeter or LeBron James yeah did
miss rice like what who are those people
it's not a good impression of oh my god
do they sell hot
that's it Javon that's a [ __ ] I've never
done that my beard and I just didn't
give a [ __ ] about anything else it's
just one thing that I like doing and
then I just you took you know it was
zero and I wanted like the master nut
that's another thing I want to talk
about is we were talking about this
before we started recording
you used to be laid all the time yeah
and now you're not yeah because you just
changed that I just changed and that
means that you're an even bigger [ __ ]
than I thought yeah because no because
he was just being late and he could
change it like that
well no means you were trying to make a
joke but I told you hurt my feelings man
like Joe I said forgive me late I don't
want to do this yeah I thought once I
went oh I'm hurting my friend I know I
looked and I go I will never be late
again
Oh interesting he has a mid late you
know what what one of the things that he
did once we were at dinner I think I
probably told this maybe on another
podcast but we were at dinner it was me
you Josh Lawson Will Sasso and Craig
culture I think in culture check what I
say Chad Cole yeah chuckles and and
someone else
yeah and Tom Cruise no it wasn't Tom
Cruise did I hang out with those guys so
I don't I always confuse them okay so
anyway yeah wasn't them okay so uh and
and I had a set and and and and Chad and
and and Josh were like yeah I don't know
I don't know if they ever see me do
stand-up so they're gonna come to the
comedy store you gonna come towards a
yeah so I got to go I wanna make sure I
get on so meet me at the Comedy Store so
I left early and then all you all you
guys want to go to the Comedy Store I
get on so I was like just so you know
everyone's coming I was got him seats I
got onstage I get offstage and I'm like
what the [ __ ] is everybody you guys
weren't there and then and then Josh or
Chad I was talking and they were like
hey yeah when you come in and I was like
what am I come in what I was like you
guys were suppose we made the comment or
the [ __ ] are you guys and he says oh you
uh Mariah said you were going up at the
improv and I was like what you said
Brian said you were you you rotate you
changed it and you were going to the
Improv hop I remember that
No was Brian doing senator no yes Oh
daddy [ __ ] just one no I actually
think it was worse than that he just
wanted to be at the improv because he
liked the hang there better and everyone
was like he just lied to them and said
nag Chris's do a setup at the improv
let's go there no it's like and I called
him like this [ __ ] and Enrico
and he doesn't say hello the first thing
because he knew like what he did was
dead yeah he picks on the phone he says
you ruined the night I went to call
Chris I called him and I get a text he
doesn't pick up the phone I get attacked
and all it says is nah yep ladies and
gentleman it is the fighter and the
Vaughan cuz yeah it is late as [ __ ] well
so we gonna strike it up bro
well it's ironic that the kid behaves
like one right that's what I can goes
bro super late lost track of time and
that and I just responded back you're 50
yeah you're 50 years old that's what
this is this Brian the kid lost track of
time
my favorite is he's gonna come back I
thought we said one yeah oh say dude
there's a pipe that busted off the 405
I'm like well no I took about five here
yeah oh come with some crazy magic --get
in here yeah right so we got him
cornered yeah we are yeah fire dude this
guy I've never been around anybody who
been around this many fires every I've
been in other other place with him oh
the huge fire huge fire on La Cienega
sure guy he told me one he goes dude a
water main broke off Pacific I know why
the [ __ ] anywhere near there I live off
Pacific yeah
there's no water main I got you know why
we na jaaye go really not that say
anything about the [ __ ] way enough
water everywhere bro well he also has a
scanner he's and here's the thing you
people that are laid in constantly late
and you know just selfish with other
people's times that's what it is it's
selfish with other people's time you
know brother yeah how its up but I saw
you last night I was just at the comedy
store it was good to draw bond is
[ __ ] amazing like it changed your
life yes and and you know and I'm happy
for him because for years nothing was
happening for him hey where's my camera
lots of things hangover yeah nothing
happened I think you're a man yeah I was
on man no one even knew gave up man
that's the message we're trying to say I
don't think that's amazing talented Fred
it happened 65 - OH - this is 65 this
podcast - Sarah boy you don't know that
60 60 like I would have want to kill
myself 60 like what am i doing with my
life
that's not my sabbatical one I earned it
all that's how I still calling myself
the kid let's have an old man wearing
hip clothes I'll [ __ ] talk like that
jo koy take it back what are you doing
right now I saw this episode of who take
it a shirt off in boxing you gon roll
the tits no I don't you have old yes
I'll take it back up
he had old man buff no I don't maybe 13
years maybe 13 that's a long last time
yeah it's like a time warp it doesn't
nothing changes Kalin doesn't get any
older as if he does so if he does yeah
just keep saying he's not older then one
day he's just not gonna show it died
from old age we're under just hating on
him he'll die in a fire I know Dino I
finally something happens finally a
water main breaks and he dies in it
that's when we find out he wasn't lying
we've got the femurs about get some new
material no all right man that's bra but
he's like Bobby Lehman I can watch his
for I can watch his show and even though
it'll evolve some it's just it's still
funny every time yeah yeah they have a
unique gift of the dynamic yeah you can
just look at them and they're funny you
know
correct it's nice but yeah there's some
element there where their punchline has
already set up because a lot of
committees you have to write the
punchline
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh
yeah but more performance comedians yeah
we're we're I think that like I always
say this about Callen I think he's
better in person than he is if you
listen I'm on audible or on visually
yeah video in person is where you get
the fool you get that fire yeah if he
shows up yeah if he shows that I took
and he shows up he's half an hour late
now that's whatever yeah and Counting
yeah this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]